-Our next guest is the author of
the critically acclaimed
book "Ohio."
His latest novel, "The Deluge,"
was published today
and is available wherever
you buy your books.
Please welcome to the show
Stephen Markley, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
I am thrilled to have you here.
I loved your book "Ohio," which
is also a long, wonderful book.
I was surprised to learn
that you had sort of
started this book
even before you started "Ohio."
This is a book 12 years
in the making.
-Yeah, started both of them
at about the same time,
set aside "The Deluge"
to finish "Ohio,"
came back to it
with about 40% of it done.
So 13 years
in the making, really.
-13 years in the making,
and it is about a
deteriorating climate situation.
And I'm wondering,
when you write a book about
our climate in 2012, do you have
to go back and change
things based on
the fact that, obviously,
it's happening -- Year in and
year out, it's getting worse.
-The hardest part about
the editing process
was making the zippers of
the teeth fit together, right?
So it had to meet the moment.
So I'm constantly revising in
these last three years
based on stuff that's happening
in the news, you know?
The situation where plot points
I'm concocting in 2012
are suddenly headlines in 2022.
And even with, like,
just a small example,
Russia's invasion of Ukraine,
I'm, like, racing back
through the book on fourth pass
to try to account for that,
because I had it
happening in 2032.
-So you were a little late.
Also very impressive.
Congratulations,
but just a little late.
Because this takes place
from 2013 to 2040.
-Yeah.
-And, again, it's this sprawling
book with all these characters.
And, you know, "Ohio,"
a lot of dark things
happen in that book, as well,
but one of the reasons
I couldn't put it down is,
I cared so much about
the characters.
And is that one of the keys
when you write a book
about this, as well?
Obviously, it's very scary stuff
you're writing about,
but what makes you
not want to put it down is,
you care about the
people in the book.
-It's scary
because it's abstract.
So I feel like the way in
is always through human beings.
And the point of a book like
this is to emotionally reorient
the reader around
what's happening
so we can actually
feel in our hearts
what the stakes of
this moment actually are.
-You have climate scientists
in the book.
Obviously, there's a great
amount of science in the book.
You, I'm assuming,
talked to many of them.
-Just a few, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean one of the big
pleasures of the process was,
I met James Hansen, who is the
NASA scientist who, in 1988,
testified before Congress,
and he was one of
the first people to sort of
bring climate change
to the public's attention.
So, he was gracious enough
to give me an hour,
and you don't even know
what you're looking for
in those moments,
but definitely shards
of that person ended up
in a character in the book.
-Do they worry --
Do scientists worry
when they talk to
a fiction writer
that you're going to take
what they say
and then put it on
the page wrong?
-I'm sure, yes,
but so does the news media.
SO, like --
-Yeah, exactly.
I guess that's probably
worse, right?
Even in, you know --
Even in this book,
a lot of the scientists
are frustrated by the fact that
they feel as though
they're trying to be
as clear as possible,
and the news media
often boils it down to the place
where it's no longer
scientifically accurate.
-Right, right.
Well, I think, like,
in approaching --
All the science is happening
in the future, right?
So I'm making guesses,
educated guesses,
about where we're going.
So there's that added layer
of fictionalizing
our very, very
serious situation.
-You got some very high praise,
which I think speaks to
the readability of this book,
because I would argue
the most readable author in the
last 100 years is Stephen King.
Stephen King wrote about
this book,
that it is, simply put,
a modern classic.
If you read this,
you'll never forget it.
Coming in January.
I'll remind you.
Prophetic, terrifying,
uplifting.
What was it like
when you saw Stephen King
tweeting about your book?
-Not bad.
[ Laughter ]
I grew up a total
Stephen King fanatic,
so basically from ages 11 to 14,
I read everything
the guy had published to
that point and continued to.
But, you know, as a 12-year-old
up until 3:00 a.m.,
reading "Gerald's Game,"
unfortunately,
I think that informed
my personality too much.
But, look, it's such an honor,
and I wrote a letter to him.
He tweeted about "Ohio."
I wrote a letter to him, like,
sent it to my editor
to send to his editor,
just basically saying like,
"Look, dude,
you are one of the reasons
I wanted to become a writer.
Like, whatever you could do,
that mesmerized me as a kid."
-That's really cool.
I want to --
mostly just because I feel like
this one is gonna really
stay with me,
a second tweet about it.
"More terrifying than
'The Stand' because it's real."
So that really
made my bones hurt.
-I just want to -- When I die,
I want to be remembered as
the guy who freaked out
Stephen King.
-Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's a good thing
to shoot for.
I do want to go back to
something he said
in the first tweet,
which is he ended by saying,
you know, again, terrifying,
but he also said uplifting.
So, you have spent
all this time.
You've talked to scientists.
You wrote this book about how
bad things could be.
And, yet, I think it's important
to say you still have hope.
Where does your hope come from?
-Yeah, okay, so,
it's not, like, in the course of
writing this novel,
I didn't feel
overwhelming constant despair.
I won't lie about that.
I think where I arrived,
though, is that, oddly enough,
there is joy and there
is privilege in being alive
in a time when
our actions as citizens
and as agents of history will
echo for what is effectively
the eternity of
human civilization.
You know, we have these
precious few years left
to set in motion epic change,
and we have every tool
we need to rapidly decarbonize
the global economy.
Renewables are
the cheapest energy, right?
We have the I.R.A. now,
the Inflation Reduction Act,
and this puts power into
the hands of every --
everybody, state, local,
like, school boards.
Like, look down at
your school board.
Like, down to that level,
we have power to decarbonize.
We crush demand for fossil fuels
by rapidly
electrifying everything.
We keep pressure on the
big banks to stop financing
the destruction of our world,
and we vote every election
no matter what
and we vote for people
who actually treat this crisis
like it's the
biggest emergency we have.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's something I think
we can all agree on.
It really is -- I can't speak to
how, back-to-back times,
you've just written these
really long, wonderful books
that are really hard
to put down.
It's such an accomplishment.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-It's so great to meet you.
Stephen Markley, everybody.
"The Deluge" is available now
wherever you buy your books,
but please support local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back.